we start in belarus where several
activists are being tried in court for
protesting against the state
belarusian video blogger and leading
opposition figure sergey sikanovsky
is one of six people facing a range of
charges
including inciting social hatred and
organizing mass disorder zikanoski was
arrested last year
after he made public his willingness to
challenge alexander le kashenka
in last year's disputed presidential
election
mrs sikonoski's mr sigonowski's wife
swetlana
took over his election campaign and her
supporters say
she won the election
well for more on that let's now speak to
svetlana tikkanovska wife of sergey
tigawski and
herself a human rights activist and
politician she lives in
exile at the moment in vilnius lithuania
what are your comments on the trial
against your husband today
um you know i can't call it trial
because it's fake trial fake judges and
fake prosecutors
that's why they made this process closed
uh this trial is uh going on not in the
court but
in prison and no advocate no
diplomates no relatives no mass media
were allowed into this court
for nobody could see how my husband and
other political prisoners are strong
not to inspire other people with their
strength but we know
that they are not innocent and they will
protect the innocence in in in behind
the bars
what do you know about the current state
of your husband how is he doing
you know his physical state of course is
not very good because he's in jail for
more than one year
already but his moral state is good he
knows that
he didn't do anything uh against law
and uh he understand that he is charged
for
nothing and he is brave he is strong
and he will protect himself so
this trial what outcome do you expect
here
you know so-called judge can
give to my husbands and other people as
many
years as they want 15 27 2 it doesn't
matter
what matters is to how release
uh all political prisoners and not let
them you know sit
as much as they could sit just how to
release a lot
well the european union imposed
wide-ranging economic sanctions
on belarus today do you think this will
help
your husband or other imprisoned
opposition figures
like roman protizovich
you know all the responsibility for for
changes in belarus lies on belarusians
themselves
but in such a situation when
in such level of repressions in belarus
we have very small window of
opportunities inside belarus but people
use
every inch of this to fight underground
but we are fighting and the european
union
we are really grateful to european union
and the usa and other democratic
countries
that they are protecting
let's say our strive for building new
democratic
belarus and you know since august we
tried
many um ways how to diplomatically
appeal to the regime
by but we went heard and sanctions
is maybe the most powerful leverage to
put pressure on the regime
to make them to understand that uh
democratic countries
are with us and they will fight also
alongside with the russians for
uh rule of law uh against violence and
those sanctions of course can have
impact
uh on the decisions that are made uh in
the regime
and we won't die like we want
negotiations with the regime about
future elections but before these uh all
political prisoners have to be released
and i think sanctions can help uh you
said that
the um that this is a case for the
belarusian for civil society in in
belarus
to sort this out do you think
the opposition is strong enough
so as opposition is the majority of
builders ends now
we asked from we are millions of people
who want
changes we have again we had very huge
level of repressions and violence inside
belarus but people are not given up
people are united as never before
and people are continuing to fight
people uh
uh you know unite in ins they
structurize themselves in
uh striking committees we have a very
good sportsman movement
medical movements so people understand
what they are fighting for and the
democratic leaders and democratic
activists are
united around one aim new elections
thank you very much thank you